SENTENCED PAUL MANAFORT EARLIER
TODAY.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE TONIGHT
ABOUT WHAT THE OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ORDERED FEDERAL
LAWYERS TO DO AND NOT TO DO
CONCERNING THE HILLARY CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE TELLS US
UNSWORN TESTIMONY ON
CAPITOL HILL, ONE OF THE
INSIDERS TOLD LAWMAKERS WHAT SHE
WAS TOLD.
>> DURING CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY
LAST SUMMER, FORMER FBI LAWYER
LISA PAGE SAID THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ADVISED THE FBI NOT
TO PROCEED THE NEGLIGENCE OF
STATUES FOR HILLARY CLINTON AND
THE MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY IN HOUSE
REPUBLICAN JOHN RADCLIFFE LED
THE LINE OF QUESTIONING ABOUT
THE STATUTE KNOWN AS 18 USC.
YOU'RE MAKING IT SOUND LIKE IT
WAS A DEPARTED WHO TOLD YOU
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO CHARGE GROSS
NEGLIGENCE BECAUSE WE ARE THE
PROSECUTORS.
PAGE INTERRUPTED, THAT IS
CORRECT.
HER TESTIMONY APPEARS TO
CONFLICT WITH AN FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY'S RECOMMENDATION ON
JULY 2,016TH AGAINST CRIMINAL
CHARGES FOR CLINTON.
>> I CAN ASSURE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THIS INVESTIGATION WAS
DONE HONESTLY, CONFIDENTLY, AND
INDEPENDENTLY.
NO OUTSIDE INFLUENCE OF ANY KIND
WAS BROUGHT TO BEAR.
>> THE REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION ENDED IN JANUARY
WITH DEMOCRATS NOW IN CONTROL OF
THE COMMITTEE'S NEW RANKING
REPUBLICAN GIVEN THE TRANSCRIPT
PUBLIC.
>> IT SHOWS AN INHERENT TWO-TIER
SYSTEM, ONE IN WHICH
HILLARY CLINTON GOT THE
TREATMENT WHERE SHE GOT, THERE
WAS MORE CONCERNED THAT THERE
WERE GOING TO CHARGE HER BEFORE
SHE RECUSED HERSELF AND MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THAT WAS NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> THE TIP OF GIVE THEM A CHART
DRAWN UP BY FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS ASSIGNED TO THE
CLINTON CASE.
FOX NEWS HAS CONFIRMED THE CHART
LISTED POSSIBLE FEDERAL STATUTES
FOR PROSECUTION.
NEXT TO GROSS NEGLIGENCE WAS A
QUOTATION, DOJ NOT WILLING TO
CHARGED US.
ONLY KNOWN CASE IS OUR MILITARY
THEY ACCUSED AND LEFT
INFORMATION.
IN RESPONSE TO THE REVELATION OF
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED THE
TRANSCRIPTS MAKE THE OBAMA
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LOOK EXACTLY
LIKE IT WAS.
A BROKEN AND CORRUPT MACHINE.
THE PAGE TRANSCRIPTS ALSO
REPORTS THAT SHE TESTIFIED THE